you know what it's time to talk about I
got the tweets I got the emails david
you're not going to talk about the hell
Hilary health situation you're not going
to talk about Hillary Clinton seemingly
collapsing and uh hurt her feet
seemingly going complete completely limp
in her having to be carried into a
vehicle after a 911 memorial event
yesterday I am going to talk about and
I'm going to talk about whether
progressives need to rethink the Hillary
health issue let's just talk through it
over the weekend Hillary Clinton had
what is being described but what was
described initially as a health episode
at a 911 memorial event as you know
there has been this narrative from some
on the right for a while Hilary is very
ill Hillary is unhealthy Alex Jones
talking about an injector that some
Secret Service guys carrying around
let's start to take a look at the video
of what took place yesterday and I'll
sort of talk us through it Hillary
Clinton reportedly overheated at this
911 memorial event and as you can see
here if you're watching basically
seeming unable to stay on her feet okay
and at one point you actually see her
feet it's almost like the the the UH the
toes of her feet are dragging and it
seems like she is completely uh not
under her own power and I have to tell
you that the narrative around the
explanation for what happened here is
not hugely convincing to me you know i
call it like i see it i am not the type
of person who is going to say uh that
that there is nothing or there is
something or whatever merely because of
the political implications the initial
claim was Hillary Clinton was overheated
uh it was in the low eighties in New
York City uh it's possible that someone
would be overheated at that temperature
but is it hugely hugely likely I don't
know the story then was that Hillary
Clinton was brought to Chelsea Clinton's
apartment in New York City and not too
long after that before uh too much time
went by she left and uh was asked how
she felt and she said she feels great
that she feels great it's sort of quick
to be feeling great but ok let's move on
later we are told by Hillary Clinton's
doctor that she has pneumonia was she
really feeling great if she had
pneumonia would pneumonia caused you to
collapse in a way where your feet
reverse under you and you have to be
carried completely not under your own
strength I don't know the answer to that
the explanation from the doctor was that
Hillary Clinton was diagnosed with
pneumonia on Friday two days before this
video was taken put on antibiotics and
advised to rest and modify her schedule
this is according to a statement by dr.
Lisa bardak uh the explanation about the
acute incident that took place yesterday
was that Hillary Clinton was overheated
and dehydrated that she was examined by
dr. burdock she has rehydrated and has
recovered nicely although she will be
canceling plans today and tomorrow on
the west coast uh I don't know I don't
know what to tell you i have been
reading every medical opinion on this
and of course just looking at 25 seconds
of video does not tell you definitively
what the diagnosis is and of the the the
explanations from doctors are quite
mixed uh there there appears to be
something very acutely wrong during this
25 second video that we played for you a
bunch of times uh is this what some
describe is walking pneumonia where you
do have an infection you are on
antibiotics but by and large you can get
through your day and you feel okay but
there can be an acute incident where uh
someone could completely be unable to
move under their own power I don't know
and I'm being totally upfront with the
audience that I don't know what is going
on here I think that absolutely the
overblown conspiracy theories about
Secret Service walking around with
injectors as alex jones claimed uh no
i'm absolutely not not there but am I
feeling like the explanation here isn't
adding up absolutely and as usual this
could just be bad handling
of the situation by Hillary's team right
the idea that oh what let's just say
that this was absolutely nothing and she
overheated and didn't feel well but then
we'll black we're actually gonna come
out and say that it's pneumonia and
maybe it was pneumonia all along but
they didn't mention it until she had an
acute incident because they thought
because of the conspiracy theories if we
come out and say on Friday Hilary has
pneumonia it's going to put even more
attention on an issue that we're trying
to distract from I don't know the answer
but it was very very poorly handled by
the Hillary Clinton team it's possible
that this is just pneumonia that this is
just walking pneumonia and the
combination of the emotion of this 911
event and the 83 degree heat and a very
very active campaign schedule and the
pneumonia and the antibiotics altogether
led to Hillary Clinton being seemingly
unable to to uh exhibit locomotion under
her own power I don't know I don't know
the answer but what I am absolutely sure
of is that now the Hillary health story
is no longer in the fringes of
mainstream uh uh corporate media and
mostly runk right-wing media this now is
a mainstream story I anticipate all of
the major networks will be talking about
this tonight and it's not good for the
Hillary Clinton campaign whatever is the
objective truth about Hillary Clinton's
health the video combined with the
changed narrative from the Clinton
campaign as to what happened here or
maybe not changed but narrative where
the pieces don't quite add up it's not
going to be good for Hillary Clinton
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / tdps I
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker calm /
tdps it costs nothing